bonjour bassem il ya eu beaucoup de
monde beaucoup d'émotion et de
revendications à ce rassemblement
effectivement à maera 7e place tu
voulais juste derrière mans la place du
trocadéro dans 16 ème arrondissement
était noire de monde et ce depuis 14h
ils sont venus nombreux à l'appel du
crif ou encore de la licra pour
contester cette décision de la cour de
cassation de ne pas mettre en place un
process suite à la mort de sarah halimi
c'était en 2007 17 un rassemblement pour
demander justice le mot d'ordre c'était
sans justice
pas de république ils étaient nombreux
non pas que la communauté juive mais
également beaucoup d'artistes ou encore
de politique valérie pécresse et xavier
bertrand l'ancien ministre luc ferry ou
encore anne hidalgo la maire de paris
qui a déclaré quand elle a pris la
parole sur la scène qu une rue de la
capitale portera le nom de sarah halimi
les trois religions a été présente des
membres de la communauté juive
chrétienne également un musulmane je
vous propose d'écouter à ce sujet l'imam
chalghoumi ou encore le rabbin match
sauf
et puis les députés à vie meilleure aux
côtés sata qui a défait contre
terroristes contre sara halimi comme ça
a été dit encore plusieurs fois
aujourd'hui
ça peut arriver à n'importe qui un juif
un musulman avec un de différentes
religions comme il ya quelqu'un
l'africain est bien sûr faux nez de tout
cela ici pour demander que la justice
soit faite
la sonorité ya dix là c'est l'unité
l'unité de toute la nation française
mais bien sûr il faut que la loi soit
changée soit adaptée à pales produire
aujourd'hui c'est quelqu'un qui reste
une influence substance le comique doris
délibéremment dame soit ne sont pas
condamner celui le symbole de l'unité
aujourd'hui toutes confessions juif
chrétien musulman athée laïc républicain
humain face a malheureusement un acte
barbare criminel qui a pas de justice on
peut pas avoir une paix sans justice
je suis un imam de drancy
d'une ville qu'elle a connu la joie la
déportation un fardeau lourd pour
l'humanité pour moi même d'être là au
21ème siècle une forme de confusion
juifs assassinés de cette manière on va
le voir sans qu'à voir la justice
pour moi c'est une honte pour l'humanité
rien n'est définitif kangourou
il faut un procès pour sarah halimi
phare française mais le simple
d'électriser cole a été tué massacré par
minute
poissant nous dit circulez ya rien à
voir il était fier et donc ya pas de
procès il n'était pas fou mais jamais
des fois il n'a jamais été un jour dans
un hôpital psychiatrique il n'a jamais
pris le moindre traitement contre une
maladie mentale
il s'est rendu en fumant de façon
excessive jusqu'à perdre le décernement
est-ce que tu ne restes une raison comme
tout le faisaient les kamikazes pendant
la guerre quand on fait les gars de gage
alors vous l'aurez compris et emilie
beaucoup de monde ici ou sur la place du
trocadéro aujourd'hui beaucoup d'émotion
des politiques des artistes notamment
gad elmaleh michel boujenah ou encore
arthur pour contester cette décision de
la cour de cassation la haute autorité a
entériné le caractère antisémite du
meurtre a déclaré qu'un possible de
juger le meurtre au vue de l'abolition
de son discernement suite à cette
affaire le garde des sceaux dupond
moretti a déclaré que d'ici à fin juin
sur la table du conseil des ministres
sera déposé une proposition de loi pour
pallier à ce vide juridique alors que de
son côté le conseil de la magistrature a
déclaré après s'être insurgé contre la
mise en cause de la justice dans ces
deux affaires à savoir celle de
viry-châtillon encore celle de sarah
halimi que la justice devait être
capable de faire son travail librement
sans aucune pression merci beaucoup pour
tout ces précisions abbas m subi merci
d'avoir suivi cette manifestation place
du trocadéro